Now having the body object from inclusion is good, but it lacks specific
information that allows us to react with our game logic code. As such, we need
some way to correlate a body to an entity that created that body. Now there's
number of ways to do this. We could create hash tables and lookups and all this
other stuff. Or, we can use one of the interesting nuances of box 2D,
specifically physics bodies in box 2D contain a user data property that can
point to any other object in memory, or some subset of data. For our purposes,
we're going to use that member and assign it to whatever the owning entity is
for this body. That way, when a collision call back occurs, each body will have
a pointer to its owning entity, allowing us to do game-specific logic as we
need to. To get started with this, we need to modify the physics engine addBody
code, and assign body.userData if a userData variable has been passed in as
part of the calling settings to this function.